alors concrètement qu'est ce que vous
proposez alors concrètement ce que nous
proposons nous proposons l'armement
l'étal de la police municipale bien
évidemment nous sommes les seuls à la
proposer depuis de manière récurrente
une hausse de 20% de la police en tenue
aussi nous proposons une la création
d'une brigade canine des transports nous
proposons aussi un numéro d'appel proxim
sécurité où les gens peuvent appeler de
manière anonyme pour faire constater une
incivilité ou ou un problème ou un
problème récurrent de la sécurité au
plus près de deux heures de leur
quotidien
nous on m'a déjà peut-être faire un tour
de table justement sur cette histoire
d'armement de la police municipale on
est bien d'accord sur armand létale un
armement et elle savait que c'est un
armement fait pour tuer sûr on est bien
on est bien d'accord sur le mot
exactement exactement quand je vois au
jeu quand je vois le quotidien et
l'actualité dramatique nous étions cet
après-midi parce qu'on a je tiens à le
dire on l'a on a distribué des tracts en
était au milieu de la population sous
sous les couleurs de feu ça fait ça fait
quand même une drôle d'impression
madame arnould vous armement de la
police municipale vous en dites quoi
qu'est ce que vous proposez pour la
sécurité c'est pas vraiment une surprise
dans notre camp notre camp politique on
est contre l'armement de la police
municipale je vais commencer d'abord par
adresser mes condoléances et ma
sympathie à la famille la victime ou si
la carte est un jeune homme est rappelé
que c'est que ces drames là qui
endeuillent des quartiers et qui touche
particulièrement les quartiers les plus
populaires de notre ville et notamment
ici le quartier de planoise
donc je vais commencer déjà par poser ça
je vais rappeler aussi que le on est là
face à planoise à un cas très
particulier qui est du grand banditisme
une guerre de territoire pour du trafic
de drogue et que ça c'est le rôle de la
police nationale et c'est pour ça aussi
qu'on a le préfet qui intervient qu on a
des enquêtes de la police judiciaire et
que en fait ça c'est le rôle de la
police nationale et qu'il faut pas
saisir prétexte de ces drames pour
parler d'un autre débat quel armement de
la police municipale puisque ce n'est
pas le rôle de la police municipale que
de lutter contre le grand banditisme et
je voudrais qu'on parle de la sécurité
et
la sûreté qui est un droit de manière
plus générale est un peu plus englobante
la sécurité la sûreté est cinglante tout
un ensemble de problèmes on va déjà
faire un tour un tour de table où cette
question avec anne vignot vous
l'armement de la police municipale pour
ou contre moi j'ai dit depuis le début
qu'il n'était pas d'accord
lille n'était pas du tout du tout adapté
d'envisager une solution à la crise dans
laquelle nous sommes
nous sommes face à du banditisme la
criminalité et du coup on a besoin de
grands professionnels enquêteurs
renseignements généraux les personnes
qui interviennent fortement on voit
aujourd'hui la berri qui est intervenu
en fin qui est intervenu hier et qui a
mis quinze personnes en garde à vue on a
besoin effectivement de nombreuses
effectif alors donc vous vous dites
police nationale or c'est très simple
moi je dis que si l'état ne que ne fait
pas son travail c'est à dire qu'elle ne
va pas mettre tout ce qu'il faut pour
protéger la population
j'irai en recours contre l'état parce
qu'il ya un article 73 de la
constitution qui dit que l'état se doit
d'assurer en continu la protection de
nous hawks et dire que si vous êtes
maire fin mars la vous attaquez déjà
l'état là dessus je dis que dès à
présent l'état finit par répondre à la
demande qui était fait et par les
habitants et par nous mêmes sur
l'importance d'augmenter les effectifs
d'augmenter les moyens en humain et
d'équipements et aujourd'hui on voit que
ça ne sera pas suffisant puisque à une
guerre qui s'est déclenchée et on est
très content qu'il ya eu cette
intervention
mais on aura besoin d'avoir une présence
forte et on continue combien de
personnes en plus rapide nouveau 40
personnes 9,40 points